and matt harvey second time he's faced
the mets up there did not fare well
jonathan vr leads off against matt
harvey falling two strikes
center field mullins on the move dives
he's got it
i don't know how he caught that
cedric the entertainer what an
incredible catch
gold glove center fielder exhibited
one out and at first scoreless game top
of the first now pete alonso who had two
home runs last night stepping in against
matt harvey history might be made alonzo
gets one on the air to center field hit
well that goes mullins to the warning
track back at the wall it's out of here
peter lonzo strikes again
his third home run in two nights a
two-run shot and the mets again have an
early two-nothing lead
number 10 for alonso
and his third in five at bats in this
series and so walker who is four and two
with a 2.17 era that's fifth best in the
national league and sixth best in major
league baseball
is going to face a team that he's done
well against in the past so let's see
what ryan mount castle can do two on two
down
last week's american league player of
the week
2-2 to mount castle
bounced into left field mullins around
third here he comes he will score the
throw comes into second and the orioles
around the board another rbi for ryan
mount castle fastball then he throws the
curveball
and it's down in the middle of the plate
and he just golfs it
saying about ryan moukas he's a big kid
or trying to get the tag play on mancini
sunday had three hits against the
indians sixth multi-hit game of the year
three hits tied his career high
and stewart goes down swinging on the
fastball and walker puts an end to the
bottom of the first
2-1 new york
and james mccann will bad he doubled
back in the first off matt harvey and
can matt harvey get one more pitch out
of trouble here in the third
there goes alonzo it's lined up the
middle base heads
in to score his vr alonzo goes to third
pete was in motion which brought the
second baseman wilkerson right to the
bag but it was a little high
for him and mccann has the two out hit
to driving a run to make it three to one
so two rbis for alonso and now mccann
drives in the third run and billy
mckinney at the plate
one two coming and mckinney lines one to
center field that's down for a base hit
alonso in the score mccann pulls in at
second billy mckinney with a two out rbi
hit and now here's kevin pillar with two
out and two on
[Applause]
and pillar drives one out to left field
back oh stewart it's out of here
kevin pillar cracks a three-run homer
his third home run of the season and the
mets have put up a five spot in the
third
seven to one new york until may 12th he
gave up seven runs
against the mets in a short stint
and here he's given up seven runs
on a fastball that was supposed to be
inside caught most of the plate and
pilar hit this out in a hurry here's
billy mckinney who had a base hit to
driving a run his last time up
and mckinney lofts one out to right
field santander takes a look and it's
out of here
billy mckinney with his sixth home run
of the year his third as a met
takes one over the scoreboard in right
field the mets third home run of the
night kevin pillar hit a three run homer
his last time up
full count pitch
and he threw it by him so two strikeouts
in the inning for pletco let's get a run
on the mckinney homer they're on top 8-1
you know you get this kind of run
support all you want to do is just throw
strikes
walker has only walked one he has struck
out five he's had the lead all the way
pitch
fast ball strike three wilkerson looked
like he was guessing he got the express
and walker
punches out his sixth of the night
and that fastball bends back over the
plate a nice two-seamer by walker to get
mullins looking seven strikeouts for
taiwan he's retired eight in a row
there's kevin pilar who broke this game
open with a three-run homer in the third
and pillar drives this one toward the
left field corner and it's out of here
kevin pillar with his second home run of
the night
had a player have a two home run game
this year until last night alonzo hit
two last night and now pilar tonight
[Applause]
mason williams lofts one deep to right
toward utah street and out of here
back to back home runs mason williams
with his first home run as a met
and the mets are just teeing off piolar
and williams go back to back
10-1 new york
[Applause]
here's alonzo
and he drives one to center field
mullins goes back to the wall he can't
make the catch
the arc comes in to score alonzo pulls
in at second base with another
well-struck hat this one a double
playing at camden yards too bad this is
the last time he'll be there for a while
yeah a little spinner in the in the
outside part of the plate just beats
mullins over his head mckinney an rbi
single a solo homer in four trips
in a uniform i'd never associated with
mckinney drives another one to deep
right field and that's out of here
billy mckinney putting the cherry on top
his second home run of the night
a three run shot five rbi night for
mckinney
14-1 new york
as lugo will make his third appearance
since coming back from his
elbow surgery oriole 9th anthony
santander freddie galvez and ryan mout
castle we all had the cards but over 6
000 at one point we have
santander down on strikes as lugo blows
them away with a fastball one down in
the ninth
three hits in the last two games for pat
valencia he's now at first base and
mount castle up he swings first ball
ropes it into right moving over as
mckinney makes the catch
two outs in the ninth inning the lincoln
first base fourteen one minutes dj
stewart's gone over three
breaking ball pulled on the ground at
first alonso makes the flip to lugo and
the mets
win a laugher in baltimore to split the
two-game series
six home runs tonight great pitching by
taiwan walker and the mets finish their
nine game trip with a winning record as
they win five and lose four on their
tour of arizona san diego and baltimore
14-1 the final tonight